I think most of people that reach
success in their life start to be afraid
of not having what they have and I think
this is the biggest mistake that
entrepreneurs make
[Music]
I am just a risk-taker they did all my
life without fear I'm not stupid I in
valuate danger but I trust that there's
intelligence behind the decision we're
making and if you want to be a
game-changer you just have to take Chris
this is our sea life so it's not
necessarily that I will recommend
everybody to go but this is my way
[Music]
always that challenge myself creatively
to come with something that are
innovative and I think the project like
py one that we're opening very soon
carry this DNA first of all the format
is different you know you see around the
world immersive experience and don't
they want to do it in the shape that is
different so the firmament was perfectly
but more than that to have the pyramid
that could relate to spirituality is
also part of the story go on and tell so
we believe we will be able to create
some amazing collective experience in an
immersive world in many different ways
the pyramid will be activated in the
morning with yoga immersive experience
then we'll have our show which is called
through the echoes which is basically
our interpretation of this journey of
life from the Big Bang to today we want
to be festive and so tonight we'll have
dancing environment where DJ will be
there and the pyramid is also able to
receive some unplug little show
conventions so I think we had created
the perfect sandbox to grow creatively
for the next 10-15 years
I pretty much I'd work on my life but I
always had this interest at the
beginning in music music was really my
first that auric enters toward the
creative side my mom was very very
creative eccentric and my father was
really a PR guy so I grew up in this
very balanced world of business and
creativity I come from a generation in
no simple family that worked art and the
visualization of security for their kids
was more toward a lawyer a doctor and so
deciding to hit the road as a busker is
definitely not the definition of they're
having their son being secured there was
a lot of conflicts in regard of me
wanting to live my life the way that I
want to live and it's really after the
signal light a second year where my mom
is like 3,000 it's like she realized
that women this was serious thing that
we were doing
I like to think that we're always trying
to create new ethos in which we will
show a creativity and I think we put
around in a format that is unique and
will be associated to learn rubbish for
a long time
[Music]